- When I'm out there riding my bike
and I have this pump on,
it's almost like it's not even there.
I just feel the freedom of being out there
and feeling the speed and adrenaline.
It's just Hannah out
there riding her bike.
Some might say I'm like Dora the Explorer,
'cause I'm always wearing this backpack.
But this backpack keeps me alive.
My name is Hannah Jordan;
I'm from Tulsa, Oklahoma.
I'm 15 years old, and I'm
a competitive cyclist.
My long-term goals are to become pro
and be in the Olympics in 2020 for Tokyo
and bring back the the
Tour de France for women.
I have an unknown rare metabolic disease.
From when I was very little, I was
in and out of the hospital
and very sick all the time.
And, when I was nine, they gave me
only a couple months to live.
So like, I sorta skipped childhood.
My mom took me all over the country
to some specialists and
they found a solution
and they gave me a thing called a G-Tube
that pumps sugar into my stomach.
It basically keeps my blood
sugar at a normal rate.
I always wanna do competitive stuff.
For most of my life,
I couldn't play sports
because of my condition.
When I got on the bike, it was almost like
my problems weren't there.
It's just been like a whole
new world opened up to me.
- This one right here is really special.
This was her first one.
And it's a silver medal,
but she'd actually
only been riding a bike two months.
And then shortly after
that, she did this one.
She did 101 miles in five
hours and 18 minutes,
which is very, very fast.
And that's kinda when we realized
that she probably was gonna
be pretty good at this.
- [Hannah] This weekend,
I will be competing in Tulsa
Tough, a three day race.
Each day, 1,000 racers compete
from six different countries
around the world.
These women are usually 20 and above.
My mom and my dad, they're
my biggest supporters.
They take me to all the races,
and help me make it in cycling.
My mom, she helps me get everything ready.
Then my dad, at the 200 meter mark,
he starts yelling.
- Let's go Hannah, let's go, go!
- [Hannah] It's like a mental marker,
of like when I start needing to sprint.
What makes me different
from other cyclists
is the ability to tap in that willpower
and determination.
I like to tell people it's
sort of coded in my DNA
to be a fighter.
Anyone that's been in the hospital
for a long time, or has
gone through some struggles,
or pain, or suffering,
they just know how to dig deep and tap in
and to be resilient.
And even if you lose some days
and you win some others,
you have to keep getting back up,
each and every single time,
to go out there and ride your bike.